the rains have stopped for now but more
than one third of the country has been
left underwater over 33 million people
have been affected now this map shows
the vast areas impacted by the floods
stretching across the entire length of
the country and in the south much of
pakistan's bread basket provinces have
been submerged raising concerns about
food security
a village underwater in pakistan's sindh
province
one of several key agricultural regions
that now resemble small oceans
many people here were poor before the
floods came
now they've lost almost everything
in those areas that are dry makeshift
camps house those displaced by the water
and farmers salvage what they can from
their fields pakistan's climate minister
says the flooding is apocalyptic and
that her country is bearing the brunt of
climate change caused by more developed
nations
pakistan is
less than one percent in the global
emissions pi if you like we hardly
contribute any of uh
emissions to the the broader emission
blanket that makes for greenhouse gases
to turn our climates into a living hell
in the northern pakistani city of lahore
the effects of the floods are being felt
in soaring prices for food and other
basic goods
prices have increased a lot because of
the floods
goods can't be transported from
baluchistan the roads are closed
our business here has almost slowed to a
stop
people can't feed their children can't
pay their rent can't even pay
electricity bills
all prices have doubled
the floods could not have come at a
worse time for pakistan where the
economy was already in crisis now the
government says it needs more than 10
billion dollars to recover from this
latest climate catastrophe
haroon janjua is a journalist in
islamabad and i asked him earlier for
more on the situation across pakistan
well the relentless moonsoon season in
pakistan has created created massive
destruction more than 1100 have been
died and 33 million houses are affected
and they are in need of help the flat
floods have destructed the
infrastructure washed away roads bridges
and crops and millions home have been
destroyed pakistan have lost their
livelihood pakistanis have lost their
livelihoods
and are living under the open sky in the
temporary camps
rescue workers still have not reached
the far-flung areas in the various parts
of the country and are using boards
camels and other means of transport
available to reach the affected people
the situation will deteriorate further
as more heavy rains are expected ahead
the government has declared
leading a national emergency
you mentioned the rescue workers not
being able to reach people can you tell
us what are the pakistani authorities
doing to help people
well the country is struggling to
provide relief as the scale of the
disaster is much higher amid the
economic crisis the government had not
planning and preparedness to cope with
this
flooding and pakistan's climate change
minister called it a serious climate
catastrophe this is the most destructive
movement season in the country's recent
history the united nations today have
issued a flash bill of dollar 160
million to help pakistanis talk with the
catastrophic floods the crisis this
summer is the latest extreme weather
event in pakistan after an intense
heatwave in the southern parts this
summer pakistan is ranked as one of the
most vulnerable countries to climate
change
now even before the floods pakistan was
in an economic crisis as you mentioned
now the government has appealed for 10
billion dollars in international aid
even with that amount of money do you
feel that pakistan is able to cope with
this situation
pakistan has just resumed the imf
program amid the grave economic crisis
and the imf will release over dollar 1.1
billion to the cash traffic economy
of the south asian country the
government said that pakistan needs more
than 10 billion dollars to repair and
rebuild infrastructure damage by the
monsoon brands and pakistan central bank
had already flagged the heavy rainfall
as a threat to the economic output and
given its devastating impact on the
agriculture sector and another crisis
food insecurity is looming in pakistan
journalist haroon janjua in islamabad
thanks so much for that update
thank you
and we can speak now to sandrine dixon
de cleves she's the co-president of the
club of rome which is an organization
working to address
pressing global issues welcome to dw
should the floods in pakistan be
recognized by world leaders as proof
finally that more immediate action is
needed on climate change
absolutely but i would also say that the
droughts across europe the heat waves
that we've been seeing the fires burning
my heart goes out to the pakistani
people but we've had floods in germany
and also in belgium last year where many
actually of our
experts from the south have been
supporting us in trying to address some
of these issues
the problem with all of these issues is
that it's the world's most vulnerable
that suffers the most whether it is in
the countries in the west where it is
often in those populations that are
already the most vulnerable within those
economies so it is absolutely clear that
this is just one of another indication
that we must start to address not only
climate change but poverty and
inequality at the same time
you just presented a new report warning
about rising global inequality and its
impact on the climate can you tell us
more about that please
yes this book which we are here today
launching is called earth for all
survival guide for humanity and it very
much looks at both the system dynamic
modeling that we've been doing with the
interrelationships between inequality
poverty and clearly the climate change
that we are seeing what we're trying to
do in that book is bring forward clear
recommendations
we've heard from your report here in
pakistan that actually the food crisis
is only continuing
some of the recommendations that we have
in this book for example of our
turnaround around food is to addressing
food stability through a food stability
board or risk management addressing also
the debt crisis by working with
governments to actually
re-integrate and shift that debt in fact
even eliminate in some cases or having
special drawing rights so what this book
actually does is look at the clear
interrelationships of the crises both
social and environmental that we have
and what are some of the solutions that
we have today
for governments to deal with the current
crises and plan for future resilience
now your report does suggest that we can
end global extreme poverty and reach net
zero emissions by 2050. is this
realistic
absolutely in fact we show that two to
four percent annual gdp figures are what
we're asking to redistribute we also
very clearly indicate that we have to
work with the world's wealthiest and
start to place a very clear tax on the
wealthiest
the 10 of those revenues really need to
to shift and actually 10 percent of the
wealthiest need to ensure that they're
only taking 40 percent of our national
incomes the the fact is that we can do
this we already have most of the
solutions in the current toolbox whether
it be tripling investments in renew in
renewables excuse me ensuring that we
move towards energy efficiency measures
moving towards regenerative agriculture
and local production for local
consumption so all of those
recommendations are in there shifting
also from growth and gdp
economic indicators towards well-being
indicators that take into consideration
social well-being as well as
environmental well-being
sandrine dickson diclave co-president of
the club of rome thanks so much for
speaking with us
thank you
and we can speak now with arief jaba
khan he's with the ngo water aid and is
in the flooded area in sindh province
thanks for uh joining us tell us what
you've been seeing where you where you
are
yeah uh thank you for having me here
we actually went to see the people
displayed displaced by the floods
and what we saw was actually because of
flooding in their areas uh people have
moved the embankments they are living on
the banks of the canals and trains that
reverse uh this province and quite a few
of our provinces so people are living
there and they are dependent on
uh you know
aid for almost everything because they
had to leave without uh you know much of
the stuff from
without taking much stuff from their
homes so they need you know they are
looking for a shelter for food water
sanitation
uh we did see some tents be provided by
the government in some areas and cooked
food being provided by some of the aid
agencies
but i think the critical issues are
around water and sanitation because
without that people living in
congregated areas the the you know the
the probability of getting diarrheal
diseases and you know and even
infectious diseases grows tremendously
you've listed off all of the things that
people
need clearly the the the need is is
great at the moment but
how do how do you get to people who are
in this kind of situation and what's the
one thing that you can help them with
right now
well i i think right now people need to
survive and this is the you know this
they are in their survival mode because
you know these are very basic human
needs that we are talking about so if
they can't even afford that at the
moment
i mean there is nothing else we can
think about uh yes the roads are
accessible because we there hasn't been
rains for a couple of days but there you
know the water is still standing and
this is the southernmost district of
pakistan so we have
uh you know the
arabian sea in front of us and you know
run of touch so water drain
is going water is going to stay with
this area for a long time and and i
think that is why the government is
asking about you know funds for not just
this phase but also for the recovery and
the rehabilitation phase as well
pakistan has been facing an economic
crisis uh for months now come the club
the floods how do you feel about the
country's ability to cope with this
scale of a disaster
well you see the thing is
if even if it had come in a country
which is you know better off than
pakistan economically
they won't have been able to to to cope
with such a huge disaster because it's
affecting all the way from the extreme
north right where i'm sitting in the
extreme south and from east balochistan
to you know to to the western parts of
pakistan so if that very you know 13
more than 30 million people being
affected and more than one thousand any
government would not be able to cope
with it and i think that's what the
government is struggling with right now
are khan of water aid thank you so much
for your time today
thank you thank you